et d'abord aussi pour assurer
l'indépendance nationale dans ce secteur
stratégique des moteurs d'avion que la
snecma elle même avait été créé à la
libération et depuis elle a conservé
bien sûr ce rôle militaire en
particulier associé aux avions d'assaut
aujourd'hui elle fabrique toujours les
moteurs des mirages comme par exemple le
m 53 qui équipe les mirage 2000 demain
le rafale dont le programme est
désormais lancée voilà avec un réacteur
steak m'a appelé m 88
mais l'entreprise s'est aussi élargi de
façon spectaculaire dans le secteur
civil une fructueuse association avec
l'américain general electric a fourni la
famille des moteurs cfm56 et ouvert le
marché américain sur les airbus mais
aussi chez boeing et chez douglas on
vole désormais avec des réacteurs snecma
rappelons enfin que l'entreprise est
aussi un groupe avec des filiales
puissante comice panneaux pour les
trains d'atterrissage par exemple et
surtout la sp qui n'est autre que le
motoriste de la fusée ariane
tout cela est technologiquement très
pointue et financièrement très lourd
propriétaire l'état
et voici quelques mois l'état
actionnaire a fait son loire plus de 2
milliards de capital supplémentaire pour
financer l'avenir un avenir qui se
présente plutôt bien en termes de
carnets de commandes
mais en terme de résultat un vrai
problème les moteurs d'avions se paye le
plus souvent en dollars